[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein ganz aktuelles video
denn wir möchten auf die messe in
hannover aufmerksam machen
dazu will nämlich jetzt am wochenende am
samstag sonntag und montag und werden
für euch da sein ich bin mit meinem
kompletten team da das heißt dass sally
team ist mit dabei unsere küche ist mit
dabei da werde ich für euch kochen und
backen morath schon ganz viele getränke
gekauft das heißt ihr werdet auch ganz
gut versorgt mit essen und trinken wir
haben viele geschenke auch mit dabei wir
haben kitchenaid dabei wusste ich gar
nicht und dann wird sicherlich das heißt
ich bin die ganze familie genau die
männer können zu mir kommen beträgt
einen kaffee oder cappuccino
unser shop ist wieder mit dabei und wir
haben das türkische kochbuch dabei auch
schon viele gefragt und ansonsten gibt
einfach nebenan die infa also das ist
auch der enforcer übrigens ist eine
kreativ messe und es ist wirklich eine
richtig tolle und auch sehr große messe
das heißt es gibt nicht nur die torten
messe und die kuchen messer wo wir eben
sind sondern es ist einfach alles da was
mit dem kreativen leben sozusagen zu tun
hat genau das scheint auch wenn
verbraucher und dabei da gibt's sogar
kinder ausstellungen also seid alles
selbst vernichten bewegen uns kommt
einfach viel los auf diese messe ist
ohnehin verbrauchen müssen kommen bei
uns besuchen und dann noch die messe
besuchen also ich werde auf jeden fall
hoffe ich wenn ich die zeit finde auch
die kreativ müsse so ein bisschen
besuchen und euch zeigen alles irdischen
zeitig haben deshalb wahrscheinlich aber
wir haben an allen drei tagen das am
samstag gerne am sonntag und am montag
sind wir da genau acht geht's genau von
morgens bis abends genau es gibt kein
programm mit st
wir wissen einfach allen drei tagen der
martini ist dabei übrigens der
kinderliedermacher machen das heißt
immer auch vor ort
musikvideo genau und er hat seine
gitarre mit dabei das heißt würde somit
nicht viel action jährige und viel zu
das könnte er wenn er bei der musik
wieder mitmachen wollt einfach schon mal
beim matti auf die homepage schauen also
dieses backe backe kuchen voller glück
lied dann könnt ihr euch vielleicht den
songtext schon mal einträgen oder
runterladen kostenlos und auch einfach
auf dem weg bis zur messe auswendig
lernen und dann können wir nämlich auf
der messe zusammen singen also ich sing
nicht aber also das wäre das wäre
katastrophal war ja was ich noch ich
weiß es zumindest was ich noch sagen
wollte es gibt karten zu gewinnen also
wir haben 50 x 2 freikarten für euch
wenn ihr also auf die messe kommen
möchte dann schreib doch bitte eine e
mail an diese e mail adresse da könnt
ihr die karten nämlich gewinnen und die
gewinner bekommen dann auch direkt im
anschluss denke ich heute oder morgen
spätestens sprechen sprechen auto ist
ganz großen gefallen
bitte schreibt uns wirklich nur wenn ihr
wirklich 100 prozent auf die musik genau
damit andere leute die wirklich dahin
kommen wollten das ja darf also 50 x 2
karten genau aber ansonsten venedig hat
nicht gewinnen solltet also der eintritt
ist nicht so teuer glaube das macht mir
echt immer drauf ja und ja jeder karten
gibt's an so schmidt sagt vor ort genau
geburt noch und ich glaube das war's wir
freuen uns sehr auf euch letztes
wochenende waren wir im globus grünstadt
da haben wir eine signierstunde gehabt
da war es auch richtig folge also es war
wirklich da war eine vita meter lange
schlange und es war auch wirklich sehr
schön dort konnte sie nicht kochen ich
war ja das ist eben immer schade also
auf signierstunden klar da geht man hin
und bücher zu signieren und so weiter
aber ich hab dann mach ich keine küche
dabei was ich sehr schade finde
aber dafür gibt es ja unsere messen wo
er uns besuchen könnt und wo ihr das
komplette stelley programm bekommt ja
also ich freu mich schon auf euch
schreibt mir einfach mal ob bekommen
werdet ich bin echt schon gespannt drauf
letztes jahr war es schon richtig schön
ich glaube dieses jahr wird noch mal ein
bisschen bisschen stellen also ich freue
mich auf euch wir sehen uns dann am
samstag sonntag oder auch montag bis
bald tschüss bis dann mit lustig machen
jetzt wäre ja